hey guys welcome back to the waterload
podcast and the last episode of season
two what a year it's been so many
absolute lads who have come on the
podcast extremely grateful for anyone
who has given up their time to come on
and to anyone who has given up their
time to listen to the podcast very much
appreciated
but this episode is brought to you by
mac finlayson what a lad he is and if
you are keen to support the podcast head
over to waterloo.com and go get yourself
some merch or coffee or even get
involved with the discounts to pure
sports cbd or mint undies anyway i got
an absolute lad for you this one so
let's get to it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a lad wow with it being the last
episode of season two it's always super
important to finish the year as strongly
as possible so i knew we needed an
absolute lad and thankfully i have got
him he is a nelson legend who has gone
on to become a star of the international
stage for ireland and on his way he has
been massive for sides including the
tasman marco the chiefs and the new
zealand maoris and of course his current
side the irish powerhouse leinster he's
also had a few bigger setbacks than most
along his way which makes for a very
inspiring story and of course he is one
of the biggest lads you will ever meet
it is the great james lowe welcome mate
cheers for the uh introduction hey jim
jeepers you make me uh you make me sound
a lot better than what i am um
i don't you can't get any higher than
arty so i'm sorry in advance you are
religion and you do have a pretty
awesome story which i have followed from
i think you were year nine i remember
coaching a nelson college year nine side
against you and mate you were just
running about even back then yeah mate
that was a few moons ago wasn't it um
bro those were the days man i love
nelson college like when i whenever i
think back to like i'm so i'm still so
like attached to it and that's like it's
it's such a good thing on one end of
this but then it's so annoying on the
other like i get into arguments with
everyone like man we would have smashed
you at school like you should have seen
my team and i'm just like mate i'm
almost 30 playing international rugby
and i'm arguing with people saying my
schoolboy team would have ripped yours
up so um no i'm very very proud of where
i come from mate and um yeah those were
the days yeah and look at you now mate
playing against the all black sport
island oh what a week that must have
been talk me through that one yeah um
mate it was it's easily the
you know the pinnacle of my career so
far um
i never in a million years would have
thought i'd experience the week that it
was
you know like
getting the opportunity to represent
ireland was amazing but then to get on
uh in front of a packed aviva stadium
against you know like 20 of my mates
they literally were standing across from
me like 20 dudes that i could tell you
that like their parents names what
school they went to like i how many
times i've played against them and then
all of a sudden where
they were in my backyard doing the haka
in front of me i was listening to my
home teams you know national anthem um
and singing the irish anthem it was um a
bizarre week in so many ways and
something that i would i would never
change crazy mate what was it like
facing the hakka ah
it was it was cool man like you know
like i've got such a huge respect and
admiration for all those boys to have
achieved what they've achieved and then
to stand in front of the hacker such a
uh as such an amazing feeling and
thought and uh davey texted me before
the game and he was like mate don't
laugh at me in the heart here like
like he's hiding in the back he does
what i used to do when i was with him
so i was in the back left no it was it
was surreal and yeah like i said
something i'll never forget and you must
have been pretty happy with your
performance out there on the field as
well especially that one moment the key
tackle i know you want to talk about
this one go on um a lot's changed i
don't actually like talking about myself
too much i used to it was me when i was
bloody 20 years old i couldn't shut up
but um i've learned a lot along the way
but look like that i mean it was a huge
moment in the game you know and
people over here were giving me stick
like why is he packed the dude can't do
you can't tackle um well i can it's just
that i was introduced to a new system
and i just it just took me a little
longer to adapt and figure it out once i
figured it out it was fine
um you know we were we're in the [ __ ]
um
you know off the back of the scrum i
think pete o'malley mr tackle a few
offloads all of a sudden davey's through
a gaping hole and um i had to come from
bloody timbuktu to try and make a read
and um sometimes sometimes you get it
right and sometimes you get it wrong and
um you know i got it right that time but
then
davey also threw one over my head that
will chip and chase the scored you know
10 minutes before that it's the nature
of the beast and may i was just happy to
have an impact on 70 minutes and
we're able to i think we went two scores
ahead because of that maybe so yeah like
it was surreal and play yeah it was nice
it was nice to you know people be
talking about something i'm not
generally talked about before and people
are like finally a cheap
on it so it was nice it was and what was
it like going up against your good mate
will jordan he's obviously given the
rundown on how to defend you what was it
like i'm going against me they're little
they're little shit's talking man hey he
didn't talk to me after the game that's
the first time i'd heard from him okay
really was you tagging me no he wouldn't
talk to me i was just like it's a game
or rugby like you'll get a chance
everyone has a sunny day and like we
were on that day you know and um now i.e
man i remember playing for tassie and
we'd sign this like kid and you know i
was actually a little bit annoyed
because i wanted to play fullback that
year coming back from the chase and
they're like look we got this kid and i
played the first game uh he was injured
or he wasn't allowed he's probably too
young to be playing might attend at the
time or something yeah um so i played
the first game against canterbury at 15.
and then the second game i actually got
i was sick oh and he was starting at 15
and i watched i was like i mean this
dude's good it was against manual too i
was like holy [ __ ]
okay
i'll stay on my lane
yeah i'll jump back out on the wing
that's fine um but no man he's he's he's
phenomenal you know like he's definitely
a born and bred cantab you can tell by
the way he talks and his mannerisms and
uh he's straight up and down you know
but um he's a great lad outside of rugby
we have a lot of laughs we used to pick
on him i'm sure everyone still picks on
him because he's
you know he's a man above his years in
terms of his age man like he's so mature
you forget that he's what 22 maybe 23
not even
like no he's he's got a big future he
definitely deserved to win that uh the
breakthrough player of the year yeah he
had a massive yeah right but you had a
you've obviously got a great success
rate against all blacks already so mate
what
what's the secret to beating them you
reckon well i might retire now and i can
say i'm the only one
um
no like
you know throughout the week when we
were watching video and we were talking
amongst ourselves you know from the
start we there was a there was
confidence there in terms of our
preparation and you know the things we
were talking about the spaces we were
seeing we knew that if we all turned up
we could definitely put in a performance
that we like that we would be proud of
and i mean teams have done that
so many times where they've gone out and
they've
fired on all cylinders and they get 60
minutes and then all of a sudden they
you know they'll score a couple of tries
and it's like jeep is what do we how do
we do this like it happens you know 90
of the time so
we'd prep very very well um
our our fords were getting off the line
and hitting people uh we were winning
collisions there was uh a sense of
urgency and intensity and the contact
you know we didn't try and buy into
guzzler and cozy and all just rubbing
heads and you know elbows on the raffle
trying to stay away from that because i
mean that's all part part and parcel of
playing you know
the best team in the world like
they they can do that because they
deliver
and we knew that we just had to do
stick to our game plan stick to what we
knew and we like when 80 minutes is up
if they've still beaten us in fair play
but you know we got it done on the day
and that was our sunny day so yeah it
was it was a good good week at the
office did retalic or any of the boys
get hold of you
no fortunately not um
no sammy was bloody squirting water on
the sideline at me like i was walking up
and down he's got
he was like jeep has made you've been
eating burgers and all this sort of
stuff like geez amazing to see you back
like you've come back from a bloody
another neck problem and it's awesome to
see you and he's just given out to me so
um no there wasn't too much is there's a
lot of mutual respect i feel like some
of my best mates are on you know play
for the abs and have been for a long
time and i knew if i was caught at the
bottom of iraq and gaza was on top of me
i wasn't coming out without blood so um
you accept it for what it is and you you
carry on yeah and and you mentioned
about the last 20 minutes of the all
blacks always being so strong did you
guys have an emphasis on that last 20
minutes in your preparation
we didn't talk about it as much it's
just like it always bloody happens you
know like they'll have 60 minutes a
pound like literally just going through
phases and wearing teams out and then in
the last 20 minutes they've fitness
shows and uh you know whether it's a
couple of lucky breaks or you give the
ball to rico or
will jordan or severis or geordie
barrett or bowden barrett like you know
and they just do their thing but uh we
knew if we stayed in it and were
physical for 80 minutes with an
intensity with the crowd
we could give it a good shot and we did
you know like uh we won that day but
like i said we got three tests against
the abs coming up next year
i know how difficult it's going to be
those three tests so we're not getting
ahead of ourselves like if we can
you know if we can put in performances
three
awesome performances like we'll be very
happy with that because we know how
difficult new zealand are to be yeah 100
it's going to be an awesome series
everyone will be looking forward to that
one now especially after they got
well and truly beaten over there by you
guys and your family will be looking
forward to seeing you as well i bet yeah
mate two it'll be two years without
seeing my my my family man
um i'm a homeboy man like i miss nelson
bloody so much man like it's you know i
know nothing's gonna change i know you
know the same people are still gonna be
there like
but
i miss it man like i miss it so so much
and it's just a shame that like i you
know what you sign up for when you when
you go and play overseas you you
understand that yeah but the fact that
it's been taken away that i can't go
home that we can't go home like that's
the thing that really sucks but you know
everyone's happy and healthy at home at
the moment so
um no we're grand i'll look forward to
getting home for a bit yeah and what
about over there is everyone healthy
over there you guys how's your covert
situation
yeah it's a bit of a she's a bit of a
[ __ ] show at the moment um
you know it's running rampant
uh
so many people are catching covert like
we were like our barber was pretty tight
you know and boys were abiding by
government guidelines but they weren't
painting up every weekend and going into
pubs and clubs you know and mix and
mingling as much with their friends but
at the moment there's a few cases and at
leinster and man like it's literally
like day by day we've only been in once
this week we've got a big european cup
fixture
um coming up on friday away in france
and like we don't at the moment the
game's on but even they've got coke in
their man it's crazy but
uh you get on with it and
if we can send 23 boys over there
they're going to do their best to come
back with um with some points hopefully
true that's crazy it's it's mental like
like even the boys who have it like none
of like all of them are fine you know
like yeah a little bit flammy and snotty
nose uh a little bit of a sore throat
but no one's had anything far that so
yeah it sucks but you know it is what it
is so what's the protocol for those guys
are they out for
two weeks
um
so they'll be so the day that they you
know test positive uh that'll be their
first day so it's ten days from there
but
i think it's like on the last three days
you have to have negative pcr tests
before you can you know leave your
quarantine but then even on top of that
like you can't then throw someone into a
professional match as well you know
straight after that you have to
you know you you want to do a week of
training pretty much before you even
consider going going toe to toe with
someone trying to take your head off so
um mate it's got to be a it's going to
be a funny old christmas but i'm happy
and healthy at the moment and that's all
i can ask for mate so you'll be on he'll
be on the plane over there for sure
captain
ah no i will not be captain uh although
i did throw that out i've got a good
relationship with the coaching staff on
my labs i can play ten i can be captain
i can kick
um but no fortunately there's still a
few uh a few old heads around and our
tens aren't haven't fallen over but i'll
be on the plane at this stage for sure
one thing new zealand listeners will be
struggling to comprehend is that you
guys are still playing over this
christmas period over there it's always
a pretty full-on time of the year for
code
mate hey like you've been over here
like
sports and christmas just shouldn't mix
like it shouldn't like
like christmas is a time for your family
christmas is a time for you know friends
and
you know being with loved ones man like
i was actually explaining this literally
all i can do right now is go for like
walks with my dog and i bumped into my
neighbor uh on the way and i was like
look like
we're genuinely the zoo like we're the
animals in the zoo we are literally the
entertainment for every other person who
gets the week or two weeks off like it's
it's stupid man like
i
it really really annoys me that you do
play over christmas and also they're the
biggest games so like
we're playing against monster away down
on tournament one of the last times i
was a red carpet for taking someone out
in the air like they hate
leinster and they hate me
and we're playing them on uh on the 26th
so
oh man like
it's just a bloodbath and
but we play new year's day as well like
how stupid is this like but
hey i don't i don't make the rules i'll
just i'll just turn up when i'm told to
and lindsay are looking as strong as
ever mate there there's such a
powerhouse of um european rugby over
there like what is it about them that
make them so good just so consistent
they yeah like it's a funny it's funny
over here like like rugby isn't the main
sport in ireland like they've got um the
gaa so the gar and hurling and that
there is
stereotypically played by
like all the everyone outside of
pretty much south dublin like south
dublin is a very niche rugby-esque sort
of place like a lot of private schools
where the boys play rugby and
dublin is like almost like the epicenter
of a lot of the very very good rugby
players that come out of ireland and
that's i mean that's a very very big
generalization there's amazing players
that come from all the other counties
don't get me wrong but a lot of those
other counties have to tussle with you
know boys going to hurling and soccer
but here that's a lot of the boys end up
pursuing rugby so almost 10 of the
current irish internationals they went
to one school
and
those boys also
would be
five years apart you know like a lot of
them played together in school so
fortunately with lindsay those boys
don't want to leave they don't have to
leave their families they're here
their grandparents played for leinster
their parents supported lens to the
season ticket holder so automatically
you have a culture of people who are so
so passionate about lens the rugby
and that there's obviously like
throughout the years become such a
strong thing that leinster use and then
you've got old heads who have been
around for years who like that's the
hardest thing to create in a club
is a sense of like purpose or identity
or i want to
represents
like the province because of how proud
you are of the province and like i man
like that's how literally i felt with
tassie yeah i absolutely love tazzy and
i would man if anyone ever like jammo
talking about the net keys like
you going to the neck i'm still pissed
off about that
um you know like stuff like like i'm
still bitter about that you know but
that's how the boys feel about linster
over here so you've got the the
hardest piece of the jigsaw already
there and embedded in so many of the
boys um that
on top of that you then get boys who
want to work hard
you've got boys who
want to perform who are striving to
perform and then yeah on top of that you
get obviously sponsorship so then like
it's just it's just a conveyor belt at
the moment of so many good things
happening at one time
and i genuinely don't see linster
fading at all the next 10 years i just i
just can't get because i've seen it's
run like an army like it genuinely isn't
you see kids
like catch past catch past like five six
seven year olds and then like kids are
being moved schools to try and get
better because they know their parents
know they'll have a better opportunity
at rugby it's just like gee because man
that's a it's a different world but um
you know with benefactors unfortunately
i landed on my feet here like i had no
idea about this you know good he told me
about
yeah it's an amazing place to go
pointing
you know like you're gonna love the
nightlife
um
and yeah like now i'm so so lucky to
have ended up in dublin like i can't
i can't begin to express how fortunate i
am man like
it's it's been an amazing journey
that's so cool so cool to hear and i'd
love to see
some crossover games between teams like
leinster and the crusaders etc would be
so cool to see how these teams compare
against each other right
yeah like it's a
man like that's i think they're doing
that world uh that club world cup or
something or something's hap like
they're trying to
um they're trying to put it in a
schedule and that would be awesome like
if like if we had the chance of playing
against crusaders it'd be so
it's so funny because we watch we watch
so much of the crusaders like in our
like team meetings our head coach man
he's
so obsessed with rugby in a good way and
that's what you need from a head coach
for sure and like
we'll be watching richie mawanga or like
the mitch drummond like throwing like
literally 15 meter flat passes from the
base of a scrum to reach you know and
then davey coming short and less
throughout the back and it's just like
jeep is this is what we should do you
know um and then like would watch out
like okay how would we do this then if
they're gonna if they have this platform
they've got a nine you can throw that
and i've got a freak at 10 who can go
step out of tackles you know like
it's um it's an amazing thing to
to think about but if it happens
i'd love that to happen yeah and what's
it been like having the south africans
in the comp over there now well
it's
it hasn't been like we haven't played
too many because of corona man like
we've
we played against two of the south
african teams at the start of this
season but we didn't play against them
last season um and then the year before
we played against the cheetahs and
the kings and like that probably they're
not the two power houses you know um so
we haven't had to play against them too
much but man they're all big bastards
they are just
like they're so big um so it's actually
a good challenge because it is something
different man because
they've got some serious athletes out
wide and then you've got these
big headers just running bloody running
lines from hell and you just uh it's fun
man but we haven't we haven't had the
opportunity to play them too much you
know it's all it's all ahead of you
anyway mate before we get too far into
it i know you do have an unreal story as
a young fella so
i'm looking forward to hearing this but
give us a rundown on your upbringing
you've given us a little bit around your
times at nelson how much you loved it
but fill us in with what you were like
as a kid
yeah so i grew up in stoke um so it's a
little suburb and
in nelson i was a very full-on kid
i was into everything i played every
sport under the sun i
i didn't think before i spoke and it got
me in a lot of trouble um
but man i just love sport and that was
that was a serious like outlet for me uh
i went to broad green and one of my
teachers thought i had adhd because i
had just way too much energy like it's
like that was literally me in a nutshell
um you know but i loved sport i was mad
and to cricket and basketball
uh athletics touch uh everything like to
me
uh
hindsight i probably shouldn't have
played too much because i
i got stuck into it because i knew it
would get me out of school like i'd do
the bare minimum knowing like i i always
knew that i was gonna pass school like
that there was but i just never applied
myself a man if i could go back like i
definitely would have man i would change
since i would have turned up for class a
lot more and i would have listened to a
lot more um
but yeah it was that was literally me in
a nutshell man i just talked too much
and i was always up and into everything
but yeah i was never a troubled kid or i
had a very very normal background you
know like
you know just a working class family
just very normal
normal upbringing so yeah it's that was
pretty much me man
and you did all these sports but you
were very good at all these sports too
weren't you you're a bit of a freak
um
[Music]
yeah uh
i like i i just love sport man like it
was it was a way i could be competitive
and unfortunately that probably got the
better of me a lot of the time where i'd
get so frustrated at myself
or
you know i actually used to cry a lot as
a kid like especially when i lost like i
used to be that kid
like i used to literally be that kid
because i was so competitive and it took
me a it took me a long time you know
until i was in my teens to really figure
it out when to really turn it on and be
competitive and when not to because i
knew that it was affecting like
relationships with people because
everyone said man i don't want to be
around this kid this is way too intense
like all the time but um yeah i just
love sport and everything like i said
man volleyball basketball cricket i
remember stephen adams pretty much
dunked on me once man called me too
small i remember bowling it's like tom
latham um man doing athletics tom walsh
was my age in athletics so man he was
like dominating me in shopping i'm just
like yeah like i have all
you know it's it's funny the people who
are like they won't remember me but now
i remember like i was like jeepers man
like i played against all these freak
high achieving new zealand athletes but
yeah man like i
loved sport i absolutely adored it yeah
and then obviously the big setback in
your childhood growing up was when you
were diagnosed with juvenile arthritis
was it about 14 years ago yeah yeah
would have been about 13 14 so um
i was actually
i was playing cricket at the time um i
just made the
the first 11 so i would have been the
end of my third form yeah
and
yeah like i was i was always bigger than
everyone so it was always
it always that always helps when you're
uh playing sport as at a young age but
well i was literally just i was down at
the nets and i was bowling and i kept
getting these rashes
and i didn't understand what it was at
the time my parents were telling me to
shower more you stink like all that sort
of thing
i don't know like it was just a snowball
effect
and then over the summer it just
developed like i was just so fatigued
all the time like which was very
uncharacteristic uh for me
uh especially over the summer man i'd
always be stuck in going a different
play in different sports and all that
and i just like i literally could barely
get out of bed you know did he was at
the hospital do i need to test people
didn't really know what was going on and
six seven months later like all this
just literally ticking on in the
background like i was still going to
school but i could barely like i
couldn't play slaughter at the time and
then
i was finally diagnosed with juvenile
rheumatoid arthritis so
um it was literally my body was kind of
attacking itself like it was just like
an over my i was just overworked pretty
much and that was my own fault not that
i knew at the time and then yeah
um so i was in hospital for
two or three days while they did tests
and gave me different um they gave me
like different pretty much antibiotics
and trying to see what would work
because it's a very
arthritis is a very broad
um disease in a lot of ways where um
like my arthritis was very very unique
where every day i'd wake up and
something else would be sore so
the main things that were sore for me
were my fingers my wrists my knees had a
little bit of my hips
so some days like my knee would be
swollen and like i hadn't walked the day
before and this thing would be swollen
and then i'd wake up the next day my
knee would be fine and i couldn't you
know pick up a knife and fork like it
was just such a weird like bizarre
disease and um they finally found like
the right medication like i was doing
blood tests and they were trying to
figure out all these different levels
and all that and um they finally got me
onto a medication
um which was fortunately subsidized by
the government at the time
um so we were playing like a 10 or a
week when if it wasn't subsidised it was
going to be two and a half grand a week
so fortunately thank you to the
new zealand health system for that um
and yeah that was literally my miracle
pill but this year went on for
a year a year and a half and the weird
thing about it as well is that it would
come and go for like three months so i'd
have three months where it'd be
absolutely fine like you wouldn't be
able to tell a thing like i'd be back to
normal and then i'd have three months on
sideline where like you know i had
parents and
friends and everyone's like man what's
wrong with you i'm like dude i just
don't have the energy i
don't really want to be here you know
and it was very um
it really sucked for my like for my
parents because there wasn't that much
information about it and like there
still probably isn't like i'm just
fortunate enough to have lived through
it and got out the other side and now
when people with kids ask me i'm like
honestly it's a rollercoaster of stuff
you just have to find what works for you
unfortunately we found the medication
the problem with the medication though
was it was a like a suppressant so it
stopped so my body was pretty much
attacking itself so i took these you
know it was actually an injection where
i had to i had like it came in like a
packet and there was a powder in one
vial
liquid and another and then the top of a
needle a syringe and i used to have to
like make the syringe
like suck the water out of the vial put
it into the other like shake up the vial
then like extract it back out and then
inject myself
um but yeah the problem with that was it
stopped my immune system from working so
i'd get sick very easy then
and then i was taking more pills on top
of that so then help man it was just
like a spiraling effect but
you know i only felt that up until like
maybe i was 16 and then i'd say i was
pretty much perfect man like i i had no
problems after that i would have days
where i would be a little bit sore you
know like kind of
like after a game you got the bangs and
bruises and that
i it kind of felt like that
but it would be on like a tuesday or
something like you know it'd be like a
random day of the week but um you know
like i've
i came out of that and i'm grand now man
like i don't have to take any medication
but i was just very very lucky nelson
actually had the right people they're
the right doctors there because some
people like say if i lived in
christchurch there's not a specific
doctor there who could treat or knew you
know what was wrong with me so they
might might have had to have traveled or
um i was just very lucky to have you
know the right person 20 minutes up the
road so
man i'm very very grateful to have come
out the other end of that yeah mate
that's crazy so it was about a three
year period where you're just
bedridden for sort of three months on
and just sort of waking up in the
morning not knowing whether you're going
to be sweet or whether you're going to
be sore
yeah pretty much my uh my sister
actually this was would have been on a
flip phone she's actually got a video of
me
and i'm literally skin and bones and i'm
using a walker
to get to like go to the toilet and
she's cracking up laughing in the
background like this pixelated video on
it on
you know like a nokia flip top or
something uh she still has that video
but um
i might let that surface one day but man
it's it's a bleak looking skinny little
moldy boy from stoke man like it wasn't
pretty
and i think i saw a photo of you with um
might have been some of the hurricane
boys did you fly up to the hurricanes
one time and get some photos with them
because you were skinny as them too
yeah i was man like i was i was so
skinny but that was i so i would have
been 18.
um
there was a few things going on then so
uh i just played schools like new
zealand school boys
the arthritis new zealand was based in
wellington so i actually got flown up by
them to go and talk to them and you know
say thank you pretty much for them like
it was kind of like a two-fold thing was
awesome for them to have a kid who had
gone through it still a bit of them and
then it was um i was also talking like
there'd been a little bit of chat about
going to wellington like i'm talking
like minuscule stuff at the time yeah
but yeah there was a photo of myself
victor vito uh
namiya telada because he had a form of
arthritis so that there was a also a
little connection there and i ah thrushy
was it jeremy thrush maybe that's why
you'll probably look skinny you're up
against three massive humans yeah
yeah very very big boys um i actually
remember seeing lima there as well
yeah a little fresh-faced lemur air
training it was at the captain's run man
um and he was still giving me [ __ ] for
running rings around me on the uh
announcing college front field man
playing against uh
wellington college the year before so uh
that's a long time ago now man that
would have been
jeep is 11 12 years ago yeah but once
you did come right you you found your
form again pretty quickly on the rugby
field anyway and you started dominating
the new zealand schoolboy scene talk me
through your years there um
yeah that was cool man like those were
the days man like that was a lot of fun
that torn we played against tonga and
australia for the new zealand school
boys we played up in
saint peter's in cambridge and then we
were down in otago boys in dunedin and
like tj was the captain uh but author
was in the front row not too many other
big big names marty mckenzie oh yeah um
you know like you had all these you know
like a lot of freaks running around um
that was a lot of fun man
a huge learning curve but yeah it was
kind of after that man i was still
probably too smart in my own head i
thought too much of myself probably a
bit back then
um and i got a bit of a realization when
i when i actually got to tassie um that
man i'm not as good as what i thought i
was anyway because when you get up
against the big boys who've been doing
it for years they um they're the ones
who really put me in my place i think
yeah how did you find that how did you
find your first year with tazzy you on
the right and saying kk was your coach
and you and him had a few few good times
together
i love kkk man like kk is my boy and
i'll defend him so the cows come home
but um man like i
man you know like i was fresh out of
school like i was new zealand schools i
i thought i was the man like i was still
a nelson like i knew everyone i was
going out on the piss every weekend you
know like as you do as an 18 year old
but yeah i just thought i was the man at
the time
man we uh
my second game was actually a shield
shield challenge uh against you boys
where bodhi came back and you you were
on the bench i think that they body came
back and you got a good memory 30 odd
points or something yeah oh yeah 30 odd
points and
it was
man oh this is it was the end of the
first half and i
hayden krebs gave me a ball off his hip
and i i went through a gap and then i
tried to throw like a 10 meter like skip
ball like where was it i forgot to hand
uh peter beef and would have scored but
um it like drifted forward or something
and went into half time we're only down
by like seven or ten we you know like
bodhi was running an absolute clinic and
we sit down we're all pretty um like
we're all pretty pumped yeah we're
definitely in this
and then kkk comes storming in
and he's like
who the [ __ ] threw that
and i just threw that i was just like
yeah that was me and i like put my hand
up because do you think you're gonna win
the game for us today what that lens
just like went through me for like a
good ten seconds
and then like the place went quiet he's
like okay split and then like backs and
forwards when the other way and i'm like
shell shocked i'm like a possum in the
headlights like abs like i've never
experienced being yelled at before and i
look i was like jesus i
i made the break but you know i threw a
bad pass like i'm sorry i'm trying my
best um and then afterwards like joey
came up to me he's like mate don't
[ __ ] worry about that old bastard and
like campbell johnson even like i'd
barely spoken and he was like he was
like an absolute legend all the boys
loved him and i didn't even think he
knew who i was he was like mate that's
[ __ ] don't worry about that like i
from that experience you know like that
was my first experience a professional
rugby i'm just like oh my god is this
what it's like um but man like it took
me
like
i could go on about okay for so long but
like i think the biggest learning it
there and it took me years to make man
like it would have taken me like four
years i reckon to really figure it out
um
to figure
not just rugby out but like in terms of
being a person like good analogy was
like i didn't like playing in the
sandpit with other people and that there
was probably me wanting i wanted to
always be in like the limelight i wanted
the names and the paper i wanted like i
wanted to be front page i wanted to
score the trial one of the ins like
that's kind of how it was and it wasn't
until i figured that out and it took me
two years super a year of super rugby to
really figure it out i'm like man the
team's going to be better if i'm better
for the team so i had to like really
grow as a person and as a player and
become
you know be a lot more open to other
people around me to
um to really learn
as a person and be a better rugby player
i think my relationships with people and
the team really started to
become a lot stronger and i was a lot
more accepted you know i was a little
bit more vulnerable like i'd actually
talked to dg david galbraith a lot about
it and he's like mate why is your
like play so inconsistent i don't know
man i think i put enough like too much
pressure on myself
um
you know i thought i was
you know two three years of playing
professional footy i thought it was
going to be an all black like all this
all this sort of stuff you know and you
know we stripped it back and
realized i was a bit of a douchebag and
thought too highly of myself and
i was reading like i deleted all the you
know like news apps and all that sort of
stuff like i just didn't
once i stopped focusing on specifically
on me i found
you know as a person as a player i got
so much better but yeah it took me
probably a bit too long to figure that
out man like i wish i had known that a
bit earlier hey that's powerful stuff
love that
one one thing i did want to talk to you
about when you were younger you missed
out on the new zealand 20s and you were
probably the star of the trials from all
accounts i've spoken to a lot of guys
who trolled and that for that side i
think i've read an article that jeff
wilson was the wing selector and he even
had you as the top winger but you still
missed out on that side so is there any
more to that i don't know man like i
yeah like that's such an interesting one
i probably in terms of my
my attitude that was probably something
that actually still stuck out was
probably still very immature at that age
but i still like man like i'm still
baffled that i didn't make that team man
like even like that that's actually
something that really kind of frustrates
me still
um if i yeah to be honest like because i
i felt at the time you know i was
playing
15 13 wing
like i was literally like
wherever you kind of needed me like i'll
just that's where i'd go like you know
and yeah like i missed out on that and
like even i remember sitting down with
jeff like youth wilson like you said and
like he's just like mate like i owed you
on my team i don't know like what went
wrong or whatever and um you know like
everyone has their reasons but that was
just such a frustrating time for me and
probably the start of a journey of why
has this happened because maybe i was
probably still a little bit immature and
they decided to go down a different
route because no one's fallen apart from
myself like um probably didn't put my
best foot forward and you know that's
how i see it now it's it's funny i was
actually listening to artie's uh yours
and artie's podcast just before
and um we're actually
it would have been that year because i
think he's a year or two younger than me
so that was his first year in the sevens
but we actually both got picked to like
after the queenstown sevens he won't
remember this but like i it was just
like literally me and him and then like
i actually chose to go with twenties
because twenty was like no we want you
to stay with us
so it was like a [ __ ] shambles man
but yeah it's uh it's see it's all these
weird things i remember when i uh when i
think back man so how did you handle
that setback from missing out on that
side did you handle it well or yeah
probably i actually remember
like i had a few sit downs with people
you know coaches and stuff and drummy
was actually shane was actually doing a
bit of my contracts at the time just
because i had no bloody idea and he was
advising me on a few different things he
actually helped me a lot along the way
he's a very good person and he always
had my best interests and
i remember sitting down with him once
and i looked like are you doing
everything in your power to make sure
that you give this the best opportunity
that you can and that's pretty much like
a you know you probably put it a
different way but that was pretty much
the gist of the conversation we had and
i was like man i don't think i am um i
started training a lot with jason
hilkemer at the time what i really
needed to do to start pushing myself and
getting the best best out of everything
and then that year playing for tasman uh
you know after the disappointment of
you know missing out on 20s to then
i played it like really well that season
you know and when super ugly teams came
calling i thought five super rugby teams
were kind of like twoing and throwing um
a funny thing about that jules hadn't
signed at the time and it was when jules
was literally at the peak of his powers
so he was at the hurricanes and he was
like he was kind of holding off on not
signing and all this thing and me being
a left winger like there's only a few
spots you know every super rugby team's
looking for every year yeah so everyone
was trying to sign jewels but then when
jules said that he was staying to the
hurricanes all like the four other
provinces were pretty much ringing
asking if i'd go down for a viewing so
man like those bloody savior boys if
they're running the cutter at the moment
yeah
how did you come to the decision to go
to the chiefs um
i sat down and i talked with um rang
at the time you know he was kansas coach
he was a bax coach uh we got a funny
relationship as well he probably thought
i was very immature that's probably why
um
and i was like look like these teams
here i know that you've probably got a
biased opinion um but what do you think
and he was like look if i was if i had
the choice
um i think the chiefs right now are the
best are the best club um and they were
they've just gone back to back
dave rennie was at the peak of his
powers did uh
wayne smith uh andrew strawbridge
uh tom coventry like they were a
powerhouse um
i talked to i should talk to tojo
because he was
me and him went up there the same yeah
um and i was talking i actually asked
man and like this was then like boys
didn't like me back then man like i
could i could say eventually
like i was i wasn't a good person back
then like and i can i was immature man i
was very very immature as a 20 year old
and i was like dude like what would you
do if you were me and he's like look
like i've been at the crusaders
um and yeah it's awesome uh they've got
a good culture they win they weren't
winning at the time but they they're
unusual but look like even ongoing like
i'm heading up to the chiefs um that
wasn't a selling point but it's like
look if i were you i would probably to
the chiefs as well
um
and yeah when i went up and uh wayne
smith picked me up and um
he was actually the only coach because i
went to all four provinces i didn't go
down to the land as i went to the blues
crusaders and the chiefs like that's the
three teams that i sort of narrowed it
down to and wayne smith was the only one
who said i was [ __ ]
like not not as blunt as that but he was
the only one who was just like look like
well you've got a lot to work on like
everyone else was telling me i was going
to be an all black if i went to there
these
he's literally the all blacks one of the
all black selectors and he was like you
are a long way off
so that was that was refreshing and it
was probably what i needed man and it
took me a good year in that chief's
environment to really grow um and really
mature and then after that man the world
was my oyster i'd
done my best i'd thrown as many punches
as i could and you know i was up against
pretty stiff competition from the other
provinces like rico iwani was just
coming on the scene jules was at the
height of his powers wasaki naholo like
there were so many great wingers and
like i've got no beef with anyone man
like
but like that was just who i was up
against like every single time i'd make
a 45-man squad but i'd never make the 33
like and that was just it yeah um
yeah that was it
mate crazy and but you made the maldives
a few times what was those experiences
like
it was awesome man i was an eye opener
um to say the least because like you
know being from nelson um
you know like my mum's like moldy she's
pretty hearty through and through but
like i wasn't exposed to the culture the
cultural side of it as much um her
family's from tauranga and matsuri um in
the bay of islands but my dad's like man
he's from a farm like in motto like
he's like a little pumpkin man
but like that was my first real exposure
to the culture and i got in
i think we just we just lost the bloody
the nike as always back then
uh the prem final
hung over the bus but you'd have to um
recite your pepe house so literally like
your
your mountain your river your parents
where they come from who you you know
like who you represents and i was hung
over the bits man and like it was my
first time i like rushed it out and i
was so nervous but it was an amazing
cultural experience um there was there's
just something about a team where you
know when you're all you know of the
same bloodline when you're all you know
representing uh more than just like new
zealand you're literally representing
you know maori and
uh
it was awesome man it was it was very
empowering in a lot of ways and i left
that tall playing good rugby and really
intrigued into the maori culture and i
mean to my ignorance i haven't delved it
very much deeper but it's something that
you know like it's awesome to be able to
represent your culture man like it's
something there's something special
about that and that's definitely like
having my moldy all black jersey hanging
up that's one of my that's one of my
prime positions
and you sort of spoke about missing out
on the all blacks
it was probably two or three years there
where you you were right on the frame
you could have been selected but you
weren't so then when did the decision
come to
chase the lens to dream and irish dream
yeah look like like i've been playing
like good rugby like i i was always in
the conversation i was always getting
phone calls by
uh fozzie and
share darren chan
the manager like all that like all the
time uh
wayne smith was always talking about
he's like there are there abouts and
i'll never get the phone call saying
i've made it you know and it was very
very frustrating i'd always um i'd
always look for feedback and stuff and
you know i was pretty much told look
we're going here and this is why you
know you're a winger uh we know you've
you know you're all you're a bit of an
all-rounder you can kick you can pass
and everything but we need that one is
to be able to finish and like man like
you look at wasaki
you look at rico you look at jewels like
i would have picked them as well over me
like you didn't need like they didn't
need me they needed
you know the big busts running over
people they needed rico to run around
people they needed wasaki you know
stepping fending grittiness teeth and
whacking people that's what they needed
um
and i felt like if i'd stayed in new
zealand i definitely would have become
an all black that's how i that's how i
feel and um
whether that was one cap or ten caps you
know i would have been a 50 test all
black i wouldn't have been
you know i would never have reached that
so
once my
you know i i was in negotiations and i
was getting a little bit shafted
they didn't think that i was going to
leave they knew that there was always
the lure of the black jersey and then
i was like look like i'm starting to get
offers from overseas and they were
trying to almost a little bit call my
bluff
and i was like no no no i'm getting this
like this is happening like i'm actually
engaging the talks now i'm on phone
calls um
these people are selling me the world
and then like even my manager he he went
to like nzru and was like look like this
is obviously my player
we're we're
seriously thinking about leaving and
they they run him but like it wasn't any
of the coaches which was a bit annoying
like and they didn't call me and that
was a little bit frustrating like i
like i can tell you right now if wayne
smith
and
no and don't get me wrong actually like
it wasn't wayne's fault wayne had no
idea this was happening and they
actually
i'll tell that very shortly but like
none of the coaches rang me and said we
want you to stay and if that had
happened
i wouldn't have left new zealand a
hundred percent there's no way
like
like imagine
like
how powerful that was and then um i
think it was like a manager or something
called my agent was like look they
wanted to stay and just like
every single one of your coaches have
his number that's what you needed to do
and so i engaged
with leinster who at the time i think
and don't quote me on this but i
actually think they were trying to find
israel bag oh yeah i think that there
was the original plan but he had
problems with his knee
and he ended up going to japan and i
think he actually never got his knee
right and that's why lindster pulled out
don't quote me on that i heard that from
a different place that might be true
might not be but um and then you know
the stars are aligned and they um they
threw a contract out there and
i talked to my parents and i'd signed
but
um when i had announced it to the chiefs
because wayne smith was part of the all
blacks coaching staff at the time so he
wasn't actually supposed to be in and
out of the chiefs but he loves rugby too
much and i was sitting down with him
that day and i told renz i was like look
i'm going to tell the team at uh in the
team meeting that i'm that i'm leaving
next year and i was very emotional as
well and smithy was there and he's just
like how are you going like all this
she's very very excited and um i'm like
oh man like i've just signed to go
overseas and he's like what and he's
just like wait what what
what do you mean like all this stuff and
i'm stuck how didn't you know this like
and that was a very frustrating thing
for me and then i i told the team and a
lot of the boys had heard whispers did
all that sort of stuff
but that was a very emotional time
because
you know like my everest then had
changed from wanting to become an all
black to
uh wanting to be financially stable
pretty much and be able to provide for
my family and uh you know with the
potential to
create generational wealth which is
something that you know i never would
have been out thought i could have been
able to achieve playing rugby and um you
know
if i'm not an idiot i can provide that
and then you know my kids could still be
able to do whatever they want and that's
now on my everest you know was a part of
it ever to play for ireland was that
ever the goal or was it more about the
financial side of things um
at the start i was like oh yeah that'd
be cool like i always wanted to play
international rugby and you know the
opportunity is there i don't even i had
no idea about leinster in terms of them
being a club or a powerhouse of europe i
knew they were good i didn't know they
they were that good um
you know and then
um i got there in the first year and it
was a massive learning curve and i was
just like jeepers man this is actually a
lot of fun i'm really really enjoying
this and there's an opportunity of
playing international rugby at the end
of it and
you know i might i might bloody try that
so um
yeah it took me
or even like
like going on a little bit sorry a
little bit further like
even like my when i
was announcing the irish squad and stuff
i was look it was an immense sense of
pride and everything but like it still
took me a year to really figure it out
like in terms of like it was another
like level up where i needed to then be
you know a little better at everything i
was doing like when i made my debut and
stuff like i was good and i was always
good i was still a bit inconsistent but
i knew they need like they needed a left
foot they didn't have a left foot so
they always kind of needed me and it
wasn't until i played really [ __ ]
against scotland away and the six
nations that i got dropped and then i
was like
[ __ ] now i really need to knuckle down
and figure this [ __ ] out um so it's just
another learning curve for me and um man
it's been a crazy journey like
talking about it and thinking back to it
now but man it's something i i
definitely wouldn't change for the world
yeah and what was it like going from
super rugby into the european style of
rugby with leinster was there a massive
adjustment there for you
yeah
um i was always told that lenster played
more of an expansive brand of rugby um
so that there was always kind of
enticing i guess but like it was um it's
the main thing is the weather
and then because the weather over here
for eight months of the year is shocking
like uh i'm talking yeah and and i know
you understand that so the pictures the
pictures aren't as good you go to some
places where you've it looks like a
prison
you've got
like
intimidating small crowds on top of you
throwing beer at you and cursing and why
have you got a top knot like
yeah you're doing your hair again number
11
it's just like all this very very
different stuff so like
with that comes a different mindset in
terms of how to play rugby and
accumulate points through pressure
through kicking through kick chase and
all that sort of carry on um but yeah
they always like i've always had a
license to be able to like express
myself with ball in hand and they'd
never took that away from me because
it's a skill set you know like the the
step defend the offload uh working with
nines and tens um quick passes the whole
basket will pass over the top playing in
behind people they never wanted to take
that away from me which i was really
grateful for because some teams here
stick so much to a system and think
this system will break teams when
yeah it's there's not as many freak
athletes there's not as many of you know
big fijians running around and stuff
like that so they have to they have to
with what they've got they've got to
play that way but um man we've got a
good we played good rugby
and leinster and i think ireland
especially against new zealand show that
we can play
you know pretty tight shapes and break
teams down with
uh short passes playing in behind off
loads so um we're definitely there's not
too much of a change from super rugby i
don't think no yeah so i know a lot of
wingers who have gone over there and
then they're straight formed into this
kick chasing winger who just chases
kicks and receives high balls but i
guess one of your strengths is your
ability to go find the ball you you're
constantly around the ball
hands on the ball for a winger you get
more touches than most so obviously that
side of your game hasn't been affected
over there no man like fortunately as
well i like my left footer which
actually means i don't have to chase too
many kicks so my 15 um hugo keenan so
he's the irish 15 and he's actually the
lens to 15 as well man he hates it but
he's very very good in the air like he's
so he's always chasing the box kicks
like i'm i'm a lot more in the backfield
but yeah it's it's it's hilarious man
it's like any sort of exit i'm like mate
get out on the wing like you're going to
chase the box
um
but yeah like as a winger like you can
offer so much than just sitting out on
the edge of waiting for the ball um you
know and i i bet my skill set now my
catch and pass and my handling to be
able to stand at first receiver from
edges and throw passes and uh work with
tens and be able to communicate to them
where spaces um
that's that that took me a while to
learn but um it was probably because i
was a bit greedy as a kid that's
probably where that actually all stems
from that like literally like where's
the ball i'm going to the ball so
fortunately that that young little
immature selfish boy uh he's paying off
another part of your game that's really
noticeable it's just the amount of
energy you have you always have a heap
of energy on the field
where does this come from is this the
add side of things
it could easily be the add side but like
fortunately like i it's a trade-off man
i know if i'm providing energy through
that energy i'm telling them
specifically like what they need to do
like that's the main thing as a as a
winger you're a communicator and i know
if i don't have to make a tackle it's
because of the energy and specific
communication i gave so everyone else
makes tackles so that there's like the
trade-off it's just like well i can be
quiet and have to make tackles or i can
be really loud tell people what to do
and then i don't have to make tackles so
that there's the big trade-off there man
um
but yeah like it's i don't know like i
i used to be
i still probably am a little bit of an
instigator in terms of like cheeky
comments and but what i do what i've
learned now was i'd never direct them
personally at people it would be like
small influential things um
cheeky stuff and i wouldn't be saying it
directly to you but i'd make sure you
hear it
um that's now what i did i used to be
horrific like used to say some really
stupid stuff that i i regret massively
um but no now i there's a bit of a
thought process behind uh a lot of the
[ __ ] that i do so oh mate we've all been
there we've all been there we've all
been there
you've got a good kiwi crew over in
leicester too you've got good layers
like jammer and stuff keeping your
company yeah man he's uh he's awesome
and he's playing out of his skin as well
he's
i know i can be biased but like what
he's brought to lancer and irish rugby
as a nine who doesn't wait for the
perfect picture who's not waiting for
everything to be set he shifts the ball
and you know some of the times you'll
pick it up and take two steps and like
the effect of that is our forwards now
have to be better decision makers it's
like [ __ ] he could do something and i
need to react and it's just like this
this culmination
of effect that he's brought to the game
he's speeding it up he's his past is
immaculate he's the fittest in the team
like by a country like not a country
mile all the nines are very very fit but
like he's very fit
quick he's witty he's a little dog man
like especially like
i'm sure he you would have seen it
heaven having him on your team but he's
still got that little mongrel in the man
um and it's good to see you man he's
he's been amazing like how he's played
in the last years he's the number one
nine in ireland by a country mile if you
ask me
right that's awesome hey it's awesome to
see him doing so well
other thing to compare over there is the
socials have you found the difference
between the two socials new zealand
social so when i was first there you
know joey was running it and it would
all you'd always punish the people who
were young so it was me
who talked too much which was me
who thought too much of themselves which
was me so i used to get punished at like
40s and stuff man like
man it was bad um new zealand qualities
i but the thing i did do is i just
accepted it for what it was so if they
told me to do something i knew that i
i'd just do it because if i fought or if
i bit back it's twice as worse and you
get then he'll get the crowd on top here
then all of a sudden um but over here um
it's good over here man like it's it's a
definitely a different culture i'd say
like the pub culture over here is a lot
more prominent um
and like it's a it's a general like uh
northern hemisphere thing because it
gets so dark so early like i think
that's why people like it'd be 3 30 it'd
be pitch black and people would be like
uh we'll knock off workers and go to the
pub won't we
or or they'll go for a pint at lunch
read the paper with you know it's it's
crazy but the socials over here man like
well i've been fortunate enough to win i
think four
four trophies since i've been here and
then those are the days of your life man
like that's the those are the best when
you see like old dogs like with their
tops off with like
literally trophies on their heads
um
you know it's like the sun's coming up
and like you're thinking about ordering
a taxi they're just like [ __ ] down
you're not going anywhere you know like
it's those are the days man like um some
of those memories like i have on my head
and i'm sure you've got some um you know
with with the shield and like stories
you don't want to tell but man they're
daisy alive i never really won too much
in new zealand um you know we won with
tazzy we never won the shield i never
won a super rugby title but yeah man
like winning trophies at the end of the
day that's like people can't take that
away from you
like
you can talk as much [ __ ] as you want
but i've got a european title you know
like you you can say i didn't tackle
that yeah i don't care i've still got
the trophy in the middle to show for it
like
man though you can you'll never take
that away from me so
it's it's been amazing over here so far
man like our team is still very very
young
with so much potential that i don't
it'll be our own fault if we don't win
you know
um so man like the dues are very very
good though there's stories i shouldn't
be telling on here
which of your trophies has really stood
out um
it was probably
the european cup in my first year and it
stood out for a few reasons so
i didn't realize how big the european
cup was yeah for one i just thought it
was another competition and it's massive
it's huge it's it's crazy it's literally
like think super rugby on steroids like
that's genuinely what the european cup
is so
in my first year at leinster you could
only play
two
aussies or kiwis
so there was three of us yeah gmo fards
and myself
and at the time like
so jammo was the reserve nine at the
time
fards was starting six and then i would
have been starting 11
but we had a lot of outside backs that
were very very good
and our third nine wasn't good so it was
always when it came to the big games
fards and gmo and i played in the
uh quarter final of the european cup
against series and series are very very
good yeah um like they're always really
really good and i had an absolute blind
i played so well and i was just like
look like there's no way i can't be
playing in the semi and then
like the coach rang me and i was i kind
of
knew that
there was a chance i wouldn't
play because of like it was the best
thing for the team was for me not to
play because we needed jammo and we
needed farts and so i didn't play in the
semi or the final but i played like
you know i played a lot of pool games
and i played awesome in the quarter and
it was such a
i feel like i handled that pretty well
and that's actually what the coaches
said they were like look you would be
starting here we want to pick you but we
can't because it's stupid rule and so
that there was it was a unique trophy to
win
and i didn't get a play in the final i
was
horrendously drunk
like uh on this trip because it was in
spain
so like we're catching a plane to spain
at seven a.m in the morning and like
it's literally all of the boys who
aren't playing were all in our suits we
have like all of the management who
aren't involved in the match day squad
like literally on a plane
and
we're literally pinting at 7 am in the
morning it was like a 3 o'clock kickoff
and oh we lit up this little bakery that
was doing like estrella on tap which was
like a cheap spanish beer but like it
was like in a bakery and they had to tap
and it was like nine o'clock in the
morning and we were just like planting
the whole time and i just remember
sprinting onto the field after uh when
we'd won that game and like the boy like
it was an amazing feeling and i like i
didn't even play and i used like
everyone still felt so i saw a part of
it but
the worst thing about that and the
changing room is that people started
pouring champagne all over me and i was
in my suit and i had to travel home so i
had like champagne beers everything just
thrown at me because it was just like
it wasn't it wasn't in a negative way or
they didn't want to have a gym they just
didn't they just wanted me to go home in
a drenched suit so i ended up having to
go home and like literally sound like a
different t-shirt different pants
someone else's shoes and socks and
underwear because people would pour in
pints all over me but that there
definitely stands out because i felt so
a part of it yet i didn't get to
experience it from the final
and
russian rusting was very very good that
day and it was like 12-9 the final score
but um that was definitely my favorite
mate goes to show your growth hey
because a highlighted game for you is a
game that you weren't playing going from
where you'd been like that wouldn't have
been anywhere near your bed would have
been the one you scored the three tries
and you got all the ball and the final
but yeah and we lost
where you feel like the biggest game
that you've been a part of is one you
didn't even play that the team once so
right huge growth from you yeah it's a
different world now isn't it yeah it's
crazy it's crazy what this has done man
like man like in terms of rugby what's
taught me so man i'm i'm very very
grateful for it and uh yeah it's
definitely
the biggest game in my career the one i
didn't play yeah you're a good cat
anyway what's the plans going forward
for you obviously the rugby world cup
we've got the three test series over
here in new zealand for ireland
you've got a few big games coming up for
leinster so
what's the goals going forward
man like six nations since the nations
big things
yes man and like i i was
only a part of one but there was no
crowds then um so six nations this year
will be a real um eye opener to see
where we're really at and um man like
we've i don't see any reason as to why
we can't put our best foot forward there
man like i know a lot of the northern
hemisphere teams are playing really
really well at the moment but like we've
like in previous years ireland probably
haven't fulfilled their potential but i
think we're taking the right steps and
playing right rugby and everyone buying
into that um so six nations um
who really want to win a european cup
and one that i get to play in i man
the three tests of new zealand like that
there's obviously in the back of my mind
like if i'm fortunate enough to tour new
zealand and then if i'm lucky enough to
play in the three test mansion man that
is
that's something that will go down as
like even for my family man like like
they've never seen me play a test match
live either yeah um so that there would
be a huge uh huge stepping stone
in terms of yeah just for my family man
that'd be really cool that's what's on
my mind and the rugby world cup uh yeah
yeah it's in the back of the mind man
like
oh
i i'm all for this eligibility rule
but we have tonga in our pool
so like the thought of
having
mala
mape
charles piazza
oh man
yeah it's
i voted in favor of it anyway so yeah
man the world cup's going to be amazing
if if i'm still playing good footing get
picked for them
um man i'll definitely put my best foot
forward it's in france um
i know that if we get through our pool
we'll either be playing against the
hosts france or new zealand
um
and because i think we it's us and
australia tonga and then scotland are in
our pool as well like so we're we're in
like literally a very very tough pool
and then our crossover games with france
or new zealand um
so man like that there would be
amazing to be a part of um something i
never thought i'd get the get the chance
to experience but um the balls in my
court and if i know i know if i stay fit
and healthy then i can i can definitely
be there so
man that's exciting exciting times ahead
for you lad and post body any plans post
footy i know you own a very good shop at
nelson crackerjack toys selling toys all
over the show
in the nelson yeah that's still going
strong yeah
yeah it is uh so my brother my brother
does that man he's the brains like he
was
um he's a very very smart man and saw
the opportunity so we uh we went half's
in that um in fairness like i don't do
much for it man he's the he's the brains
the brawn um he does all that um
post footy man like that's the million
dollar question i've been fortunate
enough to have a mentor over the side of
the world um a fellow called brian
crowley who
is in the private investment pretty much
he works for a company called broad lake
and
pretty much what they do is
kind of similar to like a dragon's den
sort of thing where they have they have
money they have um people who come to
them with they might already have an
established business who are looking to
expand they might have an idea they
don't know how to get it into production
items they don't know how to sell it and
literally people go to them and like
look this is our idea
um and then they
go forward with how they think that they
can bring their idea to life or how they
can um improve it and um so i'm working
with him and that's something that i
think that i would like to
something that i could get involved in
where i'm helping some like you know
fortunate enough what rugby's taught me
is that i've seen things from
um like the top and the bottom so i'm
literally a worker but i understand the
big picture that the coaching is trying
to achieve i've i looked to the future
and that's really that really gives me a
good perspective in terms of um what i
how i think i can help businesses so
like and i think that's how my brain is
a little bit wide in terms of trying to
like help people but then obviously
financially being able to look after it
as well um that's what i think
but man i've got no study under my belt
i don't know what i want to study and
i'm hoping uh my fiance is a lawyer so
hopefully she can i'll be a stay-at-home
dad man that's my plan
that's living
[Laughter]
exciting times ahead all around anyway
we've gone to our instagram for some
questions and james lowe the irish
legend lots of questions came in for you
lad
would you say you have a kiwi or irish
accent
um
[Music]
no i i'm still a kiwi i still have a bit
of a um nishi south dublin twang to it
i'm talking a sumo because he works with
isa nafio
um who was actually over here he's an
irish legend he's the lance the legend
um and he's like man you sound like
easter so much like you both got this
weird twang um with your kiwi accent but
um
no i'm still i've still got a kiwi x and
i don't think you'll ever get get rid of
that from me yeah fair enough okay next
one who's the biggest lad in the irish
team
we'll keep it out of the irish lads hmm
there's a lot of entertainers it's so
funny man because uh how do i phrase
this like their humor is a lot different
like you their mannerisms and their um
they're like banter is a bit different
so i had to they all think i'm like just
this big dumb idiot like when i speak
just like mate you should list like i
just don't understand what you guys are
talking about half the time but there's
some great lads man there's some really
really nice people
um
the people who i get on really well
within the irish team until literally my
best friends over here would be
um a fellow jack conan so he um he
started eight for the lions for the
three lions tests
and another guy ed burns so he's um he's
a prop for leinster and ireland as well
and we're we're pretty close friends man
we get on very very well and so do our
um partners
come a little bit easier absolutely yeah
that helps okay next one
talk us through the debut try intercept
try against the crusaders a team that
you have come out and said that you
absolutely hate
i never said that
um
it's a love hate i i because they're so
good is why i is why i hate them um yeah
you understand that um
man it's
that's a few moons ago as i do remember
it
been tummy afuna turned in to try put a
shot on i think matt todd
and matt todd flicked it away to
uh ben fernell maybe oh yeah and then
ben fernell threw it on it uh and it was
going to
who i can't remember the winger at the
time but then oh man i just stuck a hand
out
yeah i just stuck a hand out managed to
you know it was like a deflection and
then i managed to catch it and um you
know fortunately had the wheels to to go
the whole way and
um it's funny because michael ash was on
the um touchline there he actually said
he was literally there like running next
to me as i was trying to get away from
busy bag um
and yeah that was a cool moment because
i think i gave away a penalty earlier
and they went six up so
um
yeah it was it was that was a nice thing
what a try it was okay uh ireland's
chances of winning the rugby world cup
yeah like the ball is on our court man
like i think we've proved
to ourselves that we can we can compete
against the best and like i've never
been to a world cup i don't understand
the pressure i've only played three
games in front of crowds and
international rugby and they've all been
at home so my
like for me i i might have this um
a weird opinion of how international
rugby actually is because i've never
played away from home
but i don't see why
we can't top our pool
like i don't see why we can't like
playing against australia
tonga
scotland and every other team will be
thinking that as well like those other
teams will be like look we can top this
pool but man if we play the way that we
know we can play if we prepare as dylan
shouldn't be as we did against the abs i
don't see why we can't top that pool the
crossover game obviously is going to be
very very tough whether it's new zealand
or france um
and look like
i've we've proved to ourselves that we
cancel it that we can climb to those
heights we're going to have a very very
similar team to what we did um you know
a few months back now we've got all
everything's there for us man and i i
don't see why why we can't if we put our
best foot forward and the other team
beats us fair play but we're going to go
over there and make sure we don't we
don't go over there without firing a
shot
mate no doubt irish to win the world cup
you've heard it here first james lowe
i see this is why i don't actually say
it
[Laughter]
okay next question do you still rip the
o3
yeah all the time man i've still got my
tazzy tattoo
man i always rip the o3 man like every
time i score a try it's just a subtle
thing um
like i told you man i'm a homeboy i i
know i've still got a little bit of
juice left in the legs to play play
footy over here but at the end of the
day i'm probably gonna be back and
nelson
there's this nice suburban
next to the water in my pool uh there
might be a few subdivisions going up
there man it's uh who knows we uh that's
where i want to settle man i i think
it's a beautiful part of the world mate
you're going to be my neighbour oh how
good is that
oh jesus you're you're in big move
coleman
oh living okay next one who's the best
winger in the world in your opinion
good question man there's a lot of good
wingers
um you can't go past well
world was playing exceptional at the
moment
over here over this side of the world
a couple of french winners pano you're
the right winger very good uh he's the
french winger teddy toma although he's
he's he's another french winger plays
for russia um he's exceptional man he is
so so quick uh but then like i could
rattle off so many but cheers and colby
is probably my favorite winger
as well man i could go on for days
well it's crazy because all those
wingers are exceptional finishes and i
wouldn't like finishings like not my
best like bob's to weirdly rate
everything like my finishing's good but
it's nothing on those boys like
absolutely nothing so i kind of envy
them in a lot of ways and
that's a good way to be
similar question who's the hardest
player to tackle
hardest player to tackle well
i think a lot of people would say arty
like i was listening to a podcast with a
man like his
his ability to stand and tackles to be
physical um to not want to go to the
floor
um he's he's got a silly dummy that a
lot of people fall for
um
this old thing but man like his footwork
his
acceleration his ability to beat the
first tackle he initiates contact a lot
of times like you will think yeah
like trying to lean him for a hit and
all of a sudden he's hitting you
uh man he's he would be the hardest
player to tackle for sure i like that
okay two more what's johnny sexton like
he's an old man he's the second most
expensive 36 year old in the world after
ronaldo um
[Music]
he's uh he's a gene to learn man like
probably gets portrayed um in a negative
way because what you see of him is
him giving out or um
you know being a grumpy which he is
grumpy but the thing is that he wants
the best for you i think when he retires
there is going to be a massive void that
needs to be filled in irish rugby and
there's three or four tens who are
putting their hand up but i still think
sex though is the number one ten and
he's 36 man playing the best footy of
his life he's he's he's a smart
footballer he's a bit like he's he's tom
brady-esque in terms of he knows
so much about the opposite team that
he'll come to you and be like oh did you
see
the scrum where the winger went one way
to drag you so then they've got a
crossfield kick for
you know like he's he's that and tuned
um
now he's a very very good rugby player
and we're going to miss him when he you
know hopefully he's got another two
years on him
at least surely he's a lad okay last
question best piece of advice you have
for our listeners
um
oh man you put me on the spot here
um piece of advice like don't be afraid
of i guess like growth or criticism like
um
surround yourself with good people who
always have your best interests at heart
whether that's family members or friends
or even just someone you trust man who
you can go to and have open and honest
conversations with people who you know
are going to give you the feedback that
you do need because sometimes
it's hard for you to accept you're in
the wrong and like even when i think
back to me when i was 21 22 like um i
see myself then as being very selfish
and very close-minded in terms of how i
thought and how good i thought i really
was and
yeah surround yourself with good people
and don't be afraid of criticism like
make sure they've got your best interest
at heart maybe
you'll be flying it
mate i knew you'd come up trumps great
piece of advice to finish the podcast
and to finish season two of what a lad
what a year it's been and what a way to
finish it with one of the great yarns
from
such a lad james low what a journey that
was mate from going through what you did
when you're a young fella to where you
are now it's been an inspiring journey
to follow and i'm super excited to watch
you in the future with hopefully back
over here playing in these tests and
then hopefully the rugby world cup as
well i'm looking forward to what lies
ahead for you so really appreciate you
coming on the podcast mate it's been
awesome cheers mate good students so
well you're a led
[Music]
what
[Music]